hello thanks for calling mario's pizza
this is carlo speaking oh wow we
would like a large pie with
uh pepperoni pineapple and cheesy crust
large pepperoni with pineapple and
cheesy crust
we would also like a
large pie with bacon pineapple
and cheesy crust large bacon pineapple
with cheesy crust okay
is that gonna complete your order sir
you know what let me gauge the room
uh guys are we gonna want another pizza
let me just who's hungry show her hands
let me see them
one two three keep them up four
five six a party
yup pretty big one two come on guys keep
them up
hugo summer hands food you know what
let's play it safe
let's get another pie pineapple
all right um oh you guys are gonna need
cheesy crust
on the third good question i'll gauge
the room hey guys
do we want cheesy crust on the third
okay yeesh
that is a resounding yes for cheesy
crust
on the third claire says you read her
mind
claire huh i like that name it's a good
one
oh also uh my boy andy over here is
saying you have something called
chicken poppers is she cute uh who's
that
now claire oh
her body's like a four anyway we would
also
how do you mean
let's just say she's kind of a big girl
that's all good that's
all superficial man i like claire for
what's inside don't even know claire yo
but for real though
i feel like i do know claire man put me
on the phone with her
uh you don't need to speak
to claire no i do
you know what i got to level with you
man
i sir
oh oh i'm sorry i i i didn't mean to
get in between you guys no it's quite
all right
twas a while ago before she blimped up
my current girlfriends live body
tan face tan
but anyway claire yeah i hit that
sexually and uh as did my boy hugo
hell even bubba got some of that so just
wanted you to know
used goods to use goods so you wouldn't
care if i asked her out
well let me do it for you hey claire
this guy from the pizza place wants to
date you too poor all right i'll let him
down
wait wait wait wait no
tell her no i'm not a rich man
but i'm a good man tell her claire i
believe in destiny
and i believe that we've always known
that our soul mate
was out there the moment that we had
that unspoken connection about the
cheesy crust
i realized that you were always the one
because and i know this sounds corny
but that moment was just like
simple
wow you really do care about claire
i do oh my god claire just got shot
what no oh it just came through the
window it was a bullet
in the neck oh claire's down she's dead
she's dead i'm calling the cop she's
dead
well chinese it is
you